ladies and gentlemen bill burr
i love my dad and everything but you
know there's things i want to improve on
so the great thing that i have done is
my kids are not afraid of me every time
i have [ __ ] up i've gotten down to my
kids level and let them know that i was
wrong and i apologize so now my
daughter's a little bit older she's like
four and a half now so now whenever i
start flipping out she actually has been
helping me to stop
because second i hear that cute voice i
i can't i can just think that die sorry
i just immediately it's hilarious like
i'll be in the kitchen and all of a
sudden i'm always in the kitchen doing
something right and one day i just come
in like what the [ __ ] kind of toaster is
this
what was wrong with the other toaster i
gotta download i need to download the
app to make [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
she'll just be like dad don't scream
like that
and the second i hear that voice i'm
like you're right buddy you're right
buddy sorry
sorry i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
download the app here
download the app and you might would it
take you just to make